hey youtubers what's up thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Marvel Q&A lots of Marla
stuff going on right now this is mostly
going to focus on the Avengers trailer
there were a few really common questions
that everyone had so I'm gonna start
with those big stuff first there were
two women in the trailer that everyone
was wondering about as for the first one
here the best theory I've seen is that
she's part of Black Panthers honor guard
and she's gonna be part of a potential
Wakanda plot in the comics Black Panther
has a special group of female warriors
that service like badass bodyguards
Marvel's trying to get people used to
the concept of Black Panther before he
shows up in a movie there are rumors
that we'll actually see what Conda in
the film and we have ulysses cloth Andy
Serkis right here so all things pointing
to her being a black panther related
character in the vast vast realm of
speculation she could also be Black
Panthers sister I think this is much
less likely that there's a very slim
chance her name is Sheree in the comics
she takes the mantle of Black Panther
whenever he goes into a coma at some
point really soon I'll do a dedicated
Black Panther video just for that
character because he's really
interesting I just I haven't spent a lot
of time talking about him yet the really
cool thing about Black Panther stories
is they invoke a lot of mystical
elements which might lead to a Doctor
Strange point a crossover not that I'm
expecting him to be in the black panther
film until we get confirmation let's
just say she's a character tied to the
Black Panther mythos next mystery person
in the trailer this woman doing
something behind Thor looking like she's
weaving a spell while he's getting the
crap shocked out of him it looks like
they're in the middle of the fight and
she's weaving some sort of magic there's
a lot of speculation she could be
enchantress or even Halle for those that
haven't read the comics enchantress is
the older sister of Laurel I'd this
woman from agents of shield season one
she was actually really cool in that
show Halle is the child of pre ragnarök
loki in the comics after she comes of
age Odin gives her dominion over hell
also known as Niffleheim it's the
Asgardian version of the afterlife I
know it sounds like the Christian idea
of Hell like is in Hell in the devil but
really the Asgardian hell isn't all bad
and it does have a physical location on
the world tree like the nine realms it's
just the lowest of the nine realms I'm
not really sold on either one of these
theories completely yet it's possible
that Thor could be imagining what's
going on there there's this big theory
that Scarlet Witch is going to give them
all visions or nightmares however you
want to look at it so parts of this
movie could take place inside the carrot
said so in this scene here for instance
Thor could be witnessing his own
personal version of the afterlife it
just feels like a very joss whedon thing
to do deal with what's going on inside
the Avengers heads add to that that you
have the mind gem in Loki's staff here
which is responsible for Scarlet Witch
and quicksilver's powers so if scarlet
witch's powers are based on the mind gem
that she has some sort of reality or
mind-altering powers all that's just
speculation I'm sure they're gonna
explain completely what her powers are
by the third act of the movie but I
think they're gonna be really important
to the plot and the creation of the
vision who largely remained absent from
this trailer which was kind of a bummer
just to go further into the Thor
afterlife stuff so Thor 3 is called
Ragnarok and that's not the Civil War
clone Ragnarok this is like the Jack
Kirby idea of Ragnarok
he needed a Ragnarok storyline and the
Thor comics it sounds like Thor 3 is
going to deal with the idea of the
Asgardian afterlife you know namely what
happens to his Guardians after they die
Anthony Hopkins even said that Odin died
at the end of Thor 2 we just didn't see
it happen Ragnarok in the mythological
sense is about the cycle of death and
rebirth so supposedly that's going to be
going on in the Marvel Universe in like
a cosmic way we really don't know how
that's gonna play out so I don't want to
speculate too much but if Thor is gonna
die at some point in one of these movies
then he's going to have to visit the
afterlife so they'll have to introduce
that idea so it's possible that in an
age of Ultron they do that in like a
flash-forward sequence where he's
imagining himself in the afterlife the
only evidence to support any of that is
that it arose Elba spoiled a
post-credits scene I won't mention what
it is but I think most of you know what
I'm talking about it just involves two
Asgardian characters just in general
think about Marvel using the movie to
tease certain concepts like the
afterlife magic things that it's going
to be dealing with in a big way in
future films I feel like they do a
really good job of setting things up
years in advance so even if this
character isn't Halle or isn't
enchantress I do think it's someone
magic related and I do think it's an
Asgardian so now that we got through the
like the really big stuff onto some more
specific questions
Kluber asks why are the Hulk's eyes red
is he being mind-controlled by Scarlet
Witch I do think this is a very real
possibility I mean if that's gonna be
going on with the other characters you
know like what did the Romanoff girl
show you then it's possible that she's
the one that makes the Hulk freak out
there's a rumor that the Avengers have a
battle
with Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in
the early parts of the film before they
obviously turned good and start working
with the Avengers then you have this
shot here of them on the quintet looking
like they just got their asses handed to
them this could be after Scarlet Witch
messes with all their heads and gives
them crazy visions next question
look handy ass is Tony Stark in the
Hulkbuster because in the trailer you
see a shot with him in the armor right
after we saw the Hulkbuster yes that is
him in the Hulkbuster you actually
there's a bigger shot here ah she shot
it right here as you can see here like
his Jarvis heads-up display is way wider
I know it's a little confusing but he
has his normal armor on and then he
jumps into the Hulkbuster as if it's
like a shell
next question why does Black Widow look
like she's about to receive surgery so I
think that's probably from a flashback
you know if the characters are getting
visions from Scarlet Witch then she
could be revisiting when she got
brainwashed and turned into an assassin
there was a run in the comics a little
while ago that reimagined her backstory
she originally used to be a ballet
dancer and then was brainwashed and
turned into an assassin
there was actually a script for that
movie that never got made so it could be
them incorporating some of those aspects
next question
Kingdom Hearts asks what do you think of
the post that was put up by the Latino
review writer where he talks about the
spoilers for civil war Thor 3 infinity
war and Sony Marvel in the spider-man
deal the MCU so whenever it comes to
stuff like that always try to take it
with a grain of salt most of it is just
speculation on how the Avengers get
blown apart so the Avengers the roster
will be different at the end of age of
Ultron so a lot of the speculation is is
what is going to cause all these
characters to go in different directions
Thor's gonna be back in Asgard during
Thor 3 Captain America and Iron Man are
gonna be at each other's throats in
Civil War both of those movies are gonna
take place right after age of Ultron so
it just it all depends on what happens
during Avengers 2 the Spider Man stuff
is even further off so it's more than
likely what's gonna happen with Spider
Man disease Sony will make another movie
but it'll end up being a co-production
with Marvel so Marvel will have some
authorship like they'll have some say
and how the plot goes and what the
script is and who the actors are I think
in the next like four or five years Sony
is still going to retain the lion's
share of spider-man profits regardless
of who releases the film
it just it feels a lot more plausible
that Sony would make another film and
they get some help from Marvel behind
the scenes and when I say help I mean
guidance super 6 asks so actually you
had a really long question and a lot of
good stuff in it I'm actually gonna
focus mostly on what you said about
Ultron creating the vision so you
suggest that everyone creates the thing
that they fear Ultron creates vision
what does that mean that he fears so
Ultron I think ultimately fears humans
thus he creates a near perfect human
which is what the vision is there's
really too many questions about the
specifics of how that ends up happening
because it sounds like the vision ends
up getting repurposed by Tony Stark even
if he starts out being created by Ultron
it's just the interesting idea is that
Ultron creates an Android that's too
perfect so a lot of big stuffs gonna be
happening in this movie I know
everyone's wondering you know are there
too many characters is there too much
stuff going on I'll say I trust Joss
Whedon I think he was able to handle it
all although he looks like he doesn't
want to make another Marvel film for a
long long time even though he will
probably still retain a producer credit
on future films I think the most
interesting takeaway is the way the film
deals with the concept of death there
are a lot of rumors about a character
dying there are certainly a lot of
candidates especially given what's going
on in Thor Ragnarok or what's probably
going to be going on there will be a lot
more footage than released between now
and the movie coming out so they'll be a
lot more for us to talk about hopefully
some new scenes a lot of times the third
and the fourth trailer just end up being
remixes of previous trailers so
hopefully they release new footage I
wouldn't be too upset if they didn't
release footage of the vision just
because I feel like that's gonna be a
huge third act reveal Joss Whedon said
they spent a ton of time trying to get
the color right just so he didn't look
too silly
moving along congratulations to this
week's giveaway winners Vlad bayard and
Sammy Lane you guys win Amazon gift
cards is just you each win a $20 Amazon
gift card just messaged me on my channel
for contact details so I can get your
communication info a lot of you guys
said you liked the idea of doing
comixology gift certificate giveaways so
I'll try to find a way to do that with
some of my Marvel videos a lot of you
have also asked about doing another
stream I'll probably try and do another
stream next week sometime there's a lot
of big stuff coming up air on the flash
or premiering next week too so I'm
actually gonna be on a special podcast
the CW fan cast is gonna have me on
it'll be Wednesday I think like right
before the episode of arrow airs so if
you want to watch me talk to some other
people about arrow and
flash that'll be Wednesday at 4 p.m.
Pacific time it should be a lot of fun
hopefully I won't embarrass myself too
much I tend to get a little overexcited
about stuff right now if you guys
haven't seen it for like the billionth
time you can click here to watch the
Ultron trailer again and you can click
here to catch up on agent Carter from
last night thank you so much for
watching so everybody high five I'll see
you tomorrow
you